from trigger warnings to dining-hall
diarrhea college students have a lot to
worry about but we may have found an
issue that isn't just a nuisance it
could threaten their entire future Nick
quants is a college student who likes a
good house party we've had a couple here
if my roommate really likes the risky
business thing where you just kind of
wear like I guess those shirt like this
but white and your boxers are underwear
he's going to be a senior in the fall of
Chapman University located in the
peaceful picturesque city of Orange
California sometimes you'll get back to
the house around nine o'clock and there
will be a couple freshmen at your house
that thinks the party starts at nine
o'clock and no one else really gets
there till 11:00 so the parties are big
some are small and they happen as often
as you'd expect in a college town but
not everybody's happy about them they
live in a different time zone on a
different calendar
I don't want the guys peeing in my front
yard after jamming parties they're being
too rowdy or they're jumping in the pool
throw up in their yard they throw in my
ID you had probably 400 kids that were
in a backyard about three blocks from my
house that's Orange resident and City
Councilman Fred Whitaker it was out of
control was about 11:30 at night he and
the rest of the City Council recently
passed sin ordinance that tightens rules
on out-of-control parties you're trying
to create a deterrent so that people
will stay away from parties not parties
in general but loud and unruly parties
that are so bad they affect the
neighbors ability to enjoy their own
property City Council's have had to try
and make some determination how do you
affect that how do you create incentives
to not have people affect other people's
rights incentives remember that word
because this is where things start to
get rolling
bear with us as we dive into the world
of local city ordinances but here it
goes
the ordinance makes it unlawful for any
person to be present at attend or
participate and allowed an unruly
gathering and to do so in a way that
contributes to the gathering
what does present at mean well if you're
there and then you have the second
aspect of the statute you're one of the
people that's contributing to the loud
and unruly conduct here's just a little
bit more info on that contributing part
from Wayne winters the city attorney for
the city of orange the individual has to
be doing something more than just
happens to be walking by at the time or
stopping by and chatting some of the fun
yards when these happen a walk up some
indication that they are contributing to
the party maybe there was their red cup
and maybe the trumpet out the music or
whatever might be but something so in
office reserved something more than just
mere presence that seemed confusing to
us holding a red cup at a party or
jumping up and down could be evidence of
a crime we needed more specific answers
what they're really trying to get to us
who are the instigators to find
instigators who are those people well I
think what you're looking at is it's a
when you see it you know it and that's
what the police officers are there to
have discretion with we wrecked our
brains trying to figure this out lots of
things going to parties
we're throwing a Robert DeNiro party the
mother of house parties man a pajama
jammy-jam you guys are party so we just
decided to go with the basics of a
college party then maybe we'd get some
specific answers so maybe a lot of
dancing could be you know no what about
holding a red cup depends on what's in
the cup and what your age is right what
about doing like a keg stand or
something you know I think what you're
focusing on is the individual at that
party in the conduct instead of the
result of that conduct and how it
affects others it's just so vague and
also just kind of blatantly directed at
college students you can kind of pick
that out of it
but it's not even specific the kind of
partying that is going on with these
parties it's not specific in the
organized as to what it is well I think
the reason you don't want it to be that
specific is because the more specific
you get it the more that you can game
the system we're trying to cut some sort
of way to gently incentivize those who
are creating or saying they need to have
these loud ragers trying to get them to
calm it down and let it so that the
neighbors can have some peace except
that the city's way of gently
incentivizing college students is to
hand them hundreds of dollars worth of
fines that according to city code and
orange constitute a misdemeanor a
misdemeanor is a criminal offense
it means that people because they were
just present at a loud party could end
up with a criminal record there are
important consequences to a misdemeanor
conviction or any criminal record
this isn't gentle by any means that's
the Dean of UC Irvine's Law School Erwin
Chemerinsky we asked him to take a look
at the ordinance for us to help us
understand the language hey if the city
wasn't gonna get specific we needed some
guidance part of the problem with this
is it's not clearly written for example
I don't know what the difference between
present aunt and attending is I would
think president and attending are
synonyms and yet they're each listed
separately in the statute I think
whoever wrote it probably was doing
there like third graders English
assignment two and only picking out the
vocab words from that it says what you
do so in any of the contributes to the
lotta unruly gathering I assume just by
being there you're contributing to the
gathering is more required than that the
ordinance doesn't say and therein lies
the problem when a law doesn't say what
kind of specific behavior is a crime
then practically anyone can be guilty
under the Constitution any law must be
clear as to what's prohibited in what's
allowed I think one of the concerns is
that officers would have too much
discretion to be able to use it in a
discriminatory way to say we'll leave it
to
discretion of the office to decide
what's unruly by itself says this
ordinance violates the Constitution but
it sounds if the Orange City Council is
intentionally trying to violate the
rights of college students there must be
some sort of philosophy behind all this
if you understand the idea of broken
windows theory of law enforcement
quality of life the quality of life is
important to the city and stopping petty
crime and in the long run stops help
stop major crime I know this is gonna
sound wacky but let's stop here to talk
about the broken windows theory it may
have sounded like the one thing that
could have brought peace and prosperity
to disorderly be Kollek towns across
America in 1982 when two social
scientists came up with it but since
then it's been criticized over and over
again by criminologists and
constitutional lawyers for overreach
there's many problems with the broken
window theory of law enforcement first
empirically it's shown to be untrue
there's little evidence to suggest that
enforcing its minor crimes decreases the
likelihood of major crimes second it
then means that many individuals are
gonna adopt with criminal records for
minor offenses there are lifelong
consequences to their ending up with
criminal records even if it's from minor
offenses in third there's often been a
tremendous discriminatory effect to this
it's often individuals of color African
Americans and Latinos who get charged
with these minor crimes and suffer the
long lifelong consequences of the
connections
there are some parties that get out of
hand and those should be you know
contained and that this can stop with
that the language and the ordinance
specifically can kind of go after just
kids birthday parties and things that
are normal that are built in society
like having friends over during college
you're supposed to interact in a social
environment that's kind of how you
develop that's what collagen is about
and what the ordinance is kind of doing
is really restricting that does this
ordinance really support a world where
we're creating more freedom for
ourselves I think so I think it creates
a world where people feel like they are
free to have peace in their own homes
freedom depends upon everybody having
responsibility and acting responsibly
everyone should act responsibly the
question is when should the criminal law
come in when should we criminally punish
people and I think here this is an
overreaction to doubting a law that's
unconstitutionally vague it's a law that
I think is criminally punishing people
who aren't engaged in any form of crime
the orange city attorney told us that
these party misdemeanors will likely get
reduced to infractions but what about
the next City Attorney but if they're
not such a nice person as long as the
law still on the books then someone
holding one of these bad boys could get
themselves in a lot of trouble for
recent TV I'm Paul Dietrich